Should we speak in a
language before we're ready?
That's the subject today.
It comes up all the time.
People are afraid; they're intimidated.
They know that they speak with mistakes or
with a poor accent, so they don't speak.
"I would like to buy a hamburger.
I would like to buy a hamburger.
And of course you know that
I'm very much into input.
I believe that you can continue to
build yourself up, get used to the
language, develop comprehension
skills, acquire a passive vocabulary.
All of this is making you
better prepared for speaking.
But there comes a point when you have
accumulated a lot of words and you've
done a lot of listening, and at some
point you have to jump in and get wet.
And this was very much
my situation with Polish.
Eight years ago I did three months of
Polish, and then I didn't do anything.
And two months prior to going to
Poland, I spent a lot of time
listening to and reading polish.
Probably my comprehension ability—and
certainly my vocabulary—in Polish grew.
I learned more new words during
this two-month period than I have
forgotten over the past eight years.
But probably my speaking ability
was better eight years ago.
Why?
Because I spoke more eight years ago.
I had I don't know how many online
sessions during a three-month period
with my Polish tutor. And typically in
languages where the alphabet is the Latin
alphabet, or it's a familiar alphabet,
after a month or so, six weeks, with
the [LingQ] Mini Stories, I feel I'm ready
to start to struggle in the language.
And if I speak two, three times a
week, you know, the more you speak,
the better you get. As I always say, "To
speak well, you have to speak a lot."
So if you look back at my video that I
did eight years ago, I don't speak so bad.
I don't speak well, but
relative to the amount of time I
put in, it wasn't all that bad.
This time traveling with my wife
in Poland, I had the odd semi-
conversation with a taxi driver
or flight attendants on the
airplane on LOT [Polish Airlines] coming over.
Not very successful.
And then all of a sudden I was put
in a situation where I was gonna
have an interview in Polish, and
I'm going to show you this video.
At the end of this video.
You can see me speaking in Polish.
And you can also follow a link
to Easy Polish where the whole
interview was put up.
And you will see.
Comments from people that are
mostly somewhat critical of my
polish, saying that it's kind of a
mixture of Polish, Czech, Ukrainian,
and Russian. Which is true.
People saying that "Steve
doesn't speak any languages.
He's always all over the
internet pretending to be a polyglot."
A variety of negative comments.
Others are encouraging, but the point
is, I knew going in that I was not
going to speak very well in Polish.
However, tt was still, from my
perspective, a very positive experience.
I actually communicated! I mean,
if you follow the video, it's a bit
painful. I throw in some English
and various other Slavic languages.
I do my best, but we are communicating!
The person interviewing me
understands what I'm saying.
I understand what she's
saying most of the time.
So there is communication.
If I were to do that, say
night after night in Poland,
Or frequently, or three
times a week online.
My speaking ability would improve a
lot because I have this background
of passive vocabulary. But the fact
that I'm gonna make mistakes, the fact
that I'm somewhat, yeah, I would say
intimidated by the prospect of being
interviewed in Polish when I know I'm
not gonna do well, didn't prevent me
from doing it, and I'm glad I did it.
So the initial question is,
"Should we speak before we're ready?"
Well, the answer
is "You're never ready!"
We are never as good in the
language as we would like to be if
the objective is to perform well.
But if the objective is to
communicate, like if I'm in a situation,
it's going to be in Polish.
We have to communicate. I communicate.
I grab whatever I have, whatever I can
remember of Polish, whatever comes to
my mind that's in a Slavic language.
I throw in the odd English word and we
communicate. And what I hear from her is
pure, relevant, high-resonance content.
So that it's a very good experience.
So, I'll leave you the video.
You can have a look yourselves and you
can send all the critical comments you
want, but I don't mind because even if
I spend another six months working on my
Polish, improving my Polish, it'll still
not be as good as I would like it to be.
I think in language learning we're never
quite as good as we would like to be.
And yet we still have to go
there and use the language.
So my answer is, you know, should
we speak before we're ready?
Yes.
Because we're never really ready.
But we should nevertheless, you know,
try to prepare as much as we can,
focusing on our input activities.
So there you have it.
Speak when you feel like it.
Bye for now.